if you want to hear about how more do
sift monster series we talked about last
week on things you missed could tie into
Shelley the Crypt monster series I'm
gonna talk about today then stick around
to the end of this video today's video
is made possible by our sponsor crypt TV
the first episode of season two of
Shelley has just come out and as with
all of crypts 2019 productions it's part
of a greater universe there are little
clues hidden throughout about how this
all fits into the grand story that each
of these series make up but before we
get into my theory about how Shelley
season 2 fits into this universe let's
take a quick look back at season 1
season 1 takes place 20 years after the
1998 graduation at Avon Manor High
School where an introverted floor hockey
athlete hangs by the neck at the
graduation ceremony the story follows
Knicks Lauren and Heidi three bullies
who picked on Shelley and other girls
back in the day at the Reunion Heidi
fires an insult at a girl named Selene
by bringing up her old nickname blobby
Lauren excused herself to go use the
bathroom where she has a flashback of
them bullying Shelley calling her silent
Shelley and tightening the tie around
her neck
no probably not you're kind of blocking
her windpipe thing
Lauren is attacked by a monster
resembling Shelley when Nixon hide he
too got to look for her after
discovering an old photo of one Shelley
was just a level-one crook they find
Laurens jaw has been removed possibly
intended as a literal silencing in
response to their silence Shelley taunts
at ia is also tightened around her neck
they see this as a sign that someone
knows their secret but that secret has
not yet been revealed in this next scene
Heidi and Nix run into the locker room
there's a little free tip for you if the
ghost of a student-athlete is haunting
you don't go in the locker room
literally go anywhere else mix gets
picked off with a mean slap shot leaving
just Heidi remaining throughout the
school there are posters advertising a
production of Macbeth this is a fitting
reference because Macbeth is a
Shakespeare character who becomes
riddled with guilt after committing
murder we soon find that this is the
case with the bullies as well
that little necktie incident actually
killed Shelley or at least incapacitated
her so the girls make it look like a
suicide
and almost get away with it if not for
Saline aka blobby
catching them in the act the pursuer
reveals herself to be none other than
Celine and Heidi is chased into what
appears to be that Macbeth production
she almost gets away but there's a
second killer the real shelley who
finally gets her revenge hand in hand we
see that Selene and Shelley have
matching bracelets and there's a little
post credit scene hinting that in season
two Shelley's going to target the
school's staff that's where this theory
takes off with this symbol in the school
administrations office it appears to be
a ripped out page of the book like
cryptic tone which is a manual for men
to turn themselves into monsters that
appears in several crypts series this
symbol in particular is the emblem seen
on the door in the woods a crypt monster
universe short film about a colony sworn
to protect the world from a monster
known as the brutes the brood is
basically a level 50 boss if the symbol
is seen on the door and on the clothing
of everyone in the colony my theory is
that the schools in Shelley are built on
the ground upon which this colony once
resided that's right I said schools
plural it seems that Shelley's school
Avon Manor is an all-girls school
located next to the all-boys school the
headmaster of Avon Manor even says that
there's multiple schools when she talks
on the phone with hargh aides who's
presumably in charge of the boys
on top of that in this shot of hard
gates office there's a picture of the
boys school crest which is different
than the Avon Manor trust the symbol of
Avon Manor is a fox but this school
seems to have a stag which interestingly
enough is the animal head of more deer
this is a pretty small detail and it
remains to be seen if there really will
be any crossover but it's definitely
something to keep an eye on but there's
definitely a connection with the door in
the woods and I believe it has something
to do with the bracelet that Shelley
recovers from Selene which is seen to
have been originally given to her by
this guy who I would assume is Shelly's
boyfriend from the boys school the
bracelet is seen at the end of the
episode giving life to this buried
version maybe this is the reason that
brute and Shelley are seemingly
invincible this revival ritual likely
taken out of the crypts home could bring
its subject back to life and give them
new monstrous powers Shelley also has
similar themes to the door in the woods
with adults trying to keep this ancient
power hidden away from the kids and the
rest of the world in both stories
sneaking around could ruin us so it
would appear that after all this time
the powers in charge of the colony are
still trying to suppress the evil that
lies within let me know what you think
of this theory in the comments and any
other thoughts you have on Shelley
the door in the woods more do and
anything else that can be connected to
the storyline of course you'll want to
stay tuned to this entire season of
Shelley remember subscribe to Crypt TV
for new crypt monster Universe videos
every Friday bring the death valve for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive or get
brought back
[Music]